[Music]
one of the reasons I came to the MSX
program was to explore the healthcare
space much more deeply I knew I wanted
to be an investor but on what spectrum I
wasn't sure I had an interest in social
impact investing potentially doing
public equities as well as returning
into healthcare venture capital for me I
was able to experiment with all three of
those things within the last year I was
able to meet so many public equity
investors in the healthcare space and
understand the environment the culture
and whether or not it would be a fit for
me before the GSB I didn't have enough
information to make the right decision
about what would be the right role for
me but coming here meeting professors
students exploring internships and
part-time roles I feel like I have more
than enough information to make the
right decision for myself now ultimately
I felt like healthcare venture capital
was the right fit for me based on my
interest in technology helping patients
with innovative therapies as well as
working on small teens that fostered
building great companies
[Music]